I'm rushed into my research and looked
up the essay the very famous Earth Day
by Walter Benjamin and I'm just going to
read you one line quote which says
everything even the most perfect
reproduction of a work of art is lacking
in one element its presence in time and
space its unique existence at the place
where it happens to be in other words an
art of a piece of art is more than just
the object its history it's what it
absorbed it and water Benjamin calls it
aura copy doesn't have an aura about it
it doesn't have any ritual surrounding
it in terms of you know perhaps it
within a church well whatever and it can
only be a copy it can't carry that
Jonah's acquired the art of it is only a
copy but it is a perfect copy isn't it
well it's not it's the best that sense
and digital reproduction can do at least
not read from the original is it I mean
digital technology is amazing now and in
fact r'mante who had the company who
have made it are doing the best they can
do but still if the original appeared
which is not impossible because it's
said to be in a barn somewhere in Sicily
having been gnawed by rats they would
say we would all like to see how good
the replica is against the original the
original would still be the original but
there is this issue that no digital
reproduction is so good that fact Marty
claims that if they were allowed to do a
replica of the Elgin marbles the experts
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
now that starts being quite problematic
I mean this is an oil painting which
which clearly there's one original
object but a lot of our that in
photography is one obvious example
another might be the several shots that
I understand have been put in
formaldehyde for Damien Hirst I mean a
lot of art can be reproduced photography
is already different I mean you haven't
got the relationship or behind sorry we
have the thing with with with
photography
the difference between the original
prints in a modern print so that in
exhibitions we did an exhibition of
Hungarian photography and people
realized and were disappointed by the
fact that we were using modern prints
from negatives so they're close to the
original but there's still it you can
call it a snobbery
I've found it very interesting that
people have noticed that in the Royal
Collection they often display now
digital reproductions of joints they
don't want to display their Leonardo's
because the effect of light and
absolutely no I mean it's declared in
very small print and we've got used to
some level of tolerance and acceptance
of the quality of digital reproduction
so the lines are being blurred but I
mean the when you look at those drawings
for example are they inferior to the
original well I think it is problematic
we were on the island of Delos recently
and we looked at some sculptures and we
admired them and thought they were the
originals and then suddenly we realized
that actually the originals were in the
museum nearby on the island and then
immediately think oh hang on a minute
maybe I shouldn't have been mad them
quite so much we must go into the museum
to look at the original but it's a very
tricky area that's logically editing
because if you think it's the original
then your response and attitude to it
it's often the same as if it was the
original in this case you how but the
original is missing hasn't been seen
since 1969 and this facsimile is going
to go in its place yes that's absolutely
fine because we haven't got we haven't
got the actual painting style so that
may be being gnawed by rats who knows
but it isn't the same it doesn't come
with that pattern of history it doesn't
come with the whole experience of the
past it doesn't the interesting and
tricky thing is that they can now
reproduce patner because the quality
does replay
I mean Victorian reproductions reproduce
the form but they didn't really
reproduce the surface now the ability to
reproduce everything is so precise there
also is a question a much more
philosophical question whether an
artwork actually
remember something so you know whether
there is something intrinsic in the
Caravaggio that remembers his touch you
haven't got you haven't got that in in
the reproduction so there is always
going to be some sort of difference
because it's been removed divided or cut
off from the earth yeah a lot of
contemporary artists don't touch the art
you know many artists now many
academicians have huge nemesis people
working for them and it Kapoor has six
people in his studio and he himself uses
Petra Marti a lot of people don't know
that much of the work made by
contemporary artists is actually made in
Madrid by this company in fact Marte who
are incredibly skilled and they get
digital instructions from the artist
studio and then for example Grayson
Perry his tapestries which were on
display and their summer exhibition so
he'll draw them then he'll send
instructions there Madrid they adapt
them into a form and then they send them
to Brussels and a week later the
tapestry come so it just but it's it's
the sophistication about well people are
using I think what it is is that
contemporary artists use what's
available to them and now the quality of
the digital reproduction means they
using the best available thank you very
very much